[Music]
like billions of people around the world
i use google products every day we all
rely on these services loading and
reacting quickly with low latency so
data often needs to move extremely fast
from one place in the world to another
and that's not an easy task it turns out
a big part of the cloud isn't in the sky
it takes the form of fiber optic cables
like this that criss-cross the globe and
google has one of the most advanced
global networks of fiber optic cables to
understand how the network operates
let's begin at a data center
there fiber connects individual machines
then expands to connect to other data
centers in the region long-haul cables
sometimes span mountain ranges to
connect far-flung regions
to create connections between continents
our subc cables are carefully laid on
the ocean floor
let's take topaz one of our newest
subsea cables it's the only cable in
existence to directly connect canada to
asia its planning started over five
years ago
predicting capacity and building a cable
isn't easy i got to meet the teams that
made it happen
what we do is we try to look at our
current requirements from the business
and then try to predict what the demand
would be say from now to the next five
years out
cloud customers not only have an
increasing appetite for like more and
more bandwidth but they also want this
bandwidth with certain latency
guarantees by adding more diverse cables
they're essentially increasing the
reliability of the bandwidth that we can
offer them so google cloud has become a
big part of the equation but what about
increasing the capacity of the fiber
itself that's where my team comes in
[Music]
obviously replicating a 10 000 kilometer
sub seat cable in a lab is pretty
difficult we do have fiber optic spools
that are about 80 kilometers long and we
actually daisy chain these fiber optic
spools together to try to replicate a
google cloud network this optical
spectrum analyzer shows four lasers
each is carrying 400 gigabits of network
capacity per second and in total that's
1.6 terabits of zeros and ones
that's a lot of data to fit through a
fiber the width of a human hair but
another way to increase capacity is to
squeeze more fiber pairs into a cable in
2020 we were able to fit 16 fiber pairs
into the grace hopper cable instead of
the usual six or eight
that cable can transmit
340 terabits of data per second
enough to stream this video in 4k 4.5
million times simultaneously but it's
not just about capacity building a cable
takes a village and we work closely with
many partners
we rely on local partners expertise
insights and even their local infra to
facilitate our cable landings we wanna
carefully ensure minimal interruptions
to local communities such as a fishery
union and marine life heritages etc
where we are constructing those cables
one of the final steps to laying a new
cable is making sure we have the most
up-to-date electronics in place to power
it and we've made some impressive
enhancements to topaz
wavelength selective switch for
resilient and dynamic pads was first
sketched on a google whiteboard over
four years ago
now this innovation is being implemented
in topaz and adopted across the industry
[Music]
in the very early days of sub c
technology
a submarine cable was simply something
that went from one point to another
point the wavelength selective switch
allows us to effectively carve up the
spectrum on an optical fiber pair
use some for this purpose use some for
another purpose
in order to expand the capability end
users benefit from our ability to
redirect traffic on the fly so if a new
customer demands more capacity we can
run commands from a computer
and traffic shows up quickly in a
different place pretty powerful right
well cable like topaz doesn't just
improve reliability between canada and
japan it improves reliability of the
entire network google's network operates
like a mesh our organization focuses on
creating solutions that interconnect
humanity and that's really the purpose
of our network our highest priority is
to create a network that society can
depend on it all comes together on a
momentous day at shore
teams all over the world collaborate to
stretch our network fabric through an
enormous feat of partnership physics and
engineering it's our network that makes
google cloud ready for the next wave